whatever you see yourself doing now
you're marching toward purpose
meaning and impact whatever
vision that you hold for yourself see it
accomplish
and understand this it can be done
and the glue is service
belief caring
conviction and drive
hello my name is evan
evan carmichael and you've seen him i'm
sure on the line
he's a man who showcases motivational
messages
that will empower you that will help you
to get an expanded
vision of yourself that will move you to
another place
above and beyond the circumstances that
you're now facing
a lot of people are dealing with empty
pockets broken hearts and
and stress and loneliness but evan
he's taken a stance with his life and
his stance is
that you can do better his stance is
that your circumstances don't define you
his stance is
that it's not over till you win
some people say is that over till the
fat lady sings
a lot of people quit while she's just
clearing her throat
evan how are you i'm great thank you for
that amazing intro i'm i'm uh
i'm honored thank you for having me
thank you it's it's a pleasure to be
here with you
evan i i asked you before we came on
what is your signature message
and you see your signature message being
believe believe in yourself believe that
it's possible believe that it can work
out believe that someone like you can do
amazing things
i think i think lack of belief is the
single most important
issue facing us as a human species and i
wake up every day
trying to solve it one person at a time
okay now let me ask you this
where did that come from in you you're
saying
this is something that i want to talk
about in
and share with audiences around the
world and
and showcase speakers and their messages
and their values
where did that come from at the core i
think it came from my parents
they're hanging there's a picture behind
me on the wall here it's me when i'm
eight or nine years
old and and those are my parents and
they used to always tell me you're evan
castrillo carmichael you can do anything
you believe that you can
got you i want i want you to go into
your imagination and go around four or
five
and and going there who would you say
was the most
influential impactful person in your
life that you admired and looked up to
who's that person uh probably my mom
your mother what's her name anna marie
anna marie all right now i want you to
use
five adjectives and an example
anna marie give me the first adjective
and an example
what was the first quality that you
admired about your mother
service what do you mean by that give an
example
she always was
and is she's still alive trying to serve
trying to help trying to do something
bigger than herself
uh caring about her community um and
and instilled that in me too it was like
you have to go off and do more than just
for you you have to go off and serve
others too
excellent what's the second quality
um belief
whenever i was not doing well whenever i
didn't get the same grades my sisters
got
or whenever i got got into trouble it
wasn't just punishment there was always
this feeling like okay
i i can do better not that i'm i'm
bad but that i can go somewhere else and
that belief in me
helped me believe in myself a little bit
more too
excellent and the third quality
this is fun i like this you're putting
me on the spot this is great
i'm gonna tell my mom this stream
afterwards i'm sure she's gonna love it
um the family i mean she's the glue for
our family
um and just to caring for people
remembering little things like
remembering people's birthdays
she makes an annual family calendar for
us every year
so we all remember you know in our
extended family
whose birthdays are when and those
little touches
to recognize and show appreciation love
for the people
who are closest to you okay and the
fourth
fourth the conviction
to follow through she had a lot of
things stacked against her
she did things that a woman wasn't
supposed to do
in terms of leadership positions and
running organizations
where she was the first um she became
the first
chairman of an educational institution
that she changed her name to chair
so it's not just chairman um and so did
a lot of things that she was
someone like her wasn't supposed to do
an immigrant woman wasn't supposed to do
um and she just persevered her way
through it
mm-hmm i'm getting emotional less and
thinking about this
this is yeah this is great okay and so
and what's the fifth quality
fifth quality um
just a constant never-ending drive to
get better
drive strive striving to get better um
that good enough isn't good enough that
you can always do more
that one of the things she would always
say is if you have the ability you have
the responsibility
if you can then you must some
words kind of every time i want i mean
i've got five pictures in my office and
they're in the middle
and every time i walk in i hear some of
those phrases
every single time fill in my head
excellent if you wrote a book about your
mother i think you should
i you know i talk about my mother amy
brown i'm a doctor then
and i just just a few weeks ago
saw a picture of my birth mother
and my my birth mother gave me life but
my
adopted mother taught me how to live
life but if you
wrote a book about her and what you
learned from her and how to live
life what would that title be and a
title
that would appeal to anybody re
regardless of their gender regardless of
their politics in
religious persuasion young oh what would
that title be
about anna marie what would that title
be
it can be done it can be done
oh i love that can be
done and the subtitle
um that we don't want to make a gender
specific
uh the subtitle would be
your march to find
meaning and purpose
your marge define meaning and purpose
excellent do you mind if i take a swing
at your story this is a signature story
i believe
let's go hello my name is evan and i i
want to talk to you about your goals and
dreams and things that you want
to achieve with your life and i want you
to think about them in your personal
life
things that you want to achieve and
and in my case i'm living
the life that i love and i love the life
that i live
because my mother raised me to be
the kind of person to want to make the
world a better place than
how it is right now so i want you to
think about something in your personal
life that you'd like to do
or someone you you'd like to do
something for then i want you to think
about
your financial freedom number you know
people say money won't make you happy
but there was something that uh i
believe in very strongly
it can't make you happy but the people
who say that
just never had any
red fox say money ain't everything but
it can sure make a down payment on what
you want
so i want you to think about your
financial freedom number or doing
something a job or
some cause that you want to represent
and that brings me to
i want you to think about your life
living a life that will outlive you as i
look at and reflect on my mother every
time i come in the office i see her
picture and i realize
she resonated with the words of her's
man
who said we should be ashamed to die
until we made some major contribution to
humankind
and as you reflect on and looking at
your life in
and out of the pandemic
and as all of us i think are in a place
where
we we are marching toward finding
meaning and purpose in our lives
i want you to write this down service
my mother anna marie she she believed in
service
my favorite book says that the greatest
among you will be
your servant and it was earl nightingale
who said that
your success in life or failure
is directly related to the quality and
the quantity
of the service that you provide as you
look at yourself and look at your
life right now what service can you
provide
in and out of the pandemic that will
make a tremendous
impact that will make your life count
that will
be able to establish you as a person
who lived a meaningful purposeful life
and made a difference for others it was
john h johnson who with a 500 loan
from his mother and he built a 400
million dollar empire he said
there's no defense against an excellence
of service that meets
pressing public need have a service
driven
life that's what i learned from my
mother
anna marie here's the next thing belief
you know when i failed in school there
were times i felt down on myself
but she didn't criticize me she didn't
beat up on me
she just made me feel i can do better
she had high expectations for me
no one rises to low expectations
and she let me know that she expected
more
she let me know that i have the ability
to do more she let me know that the
grades
did not define me and that inspired me
to live an inspired life that that
brought
something out of me that even now i talk
about service and
and belief because i know that i'm not
just a messenger
but i am the message when you have
someone
that can believe in you before your
belief
kicks in and that's what my mother did
for me
and the next thing is caring oh boy she
did not forget birthdays and
anniversaries
you know it was my angelos that people
don't care
how much you know until they know
how much you care and my mother she
she not cared just for me but for the
family for
everybody everybody know that my mother
has a
a big heart a heart centered life
and she shared her caring with those in
the family
and people that she met it's been said
that love inspiration
and caring are perfumes you can't
sprinkle on others
without getting a few drops on yourself
live a life
of caring and the next thing is
conviction whatever goals and dreams
that
you're going after that you see for
yourself you must be
convicted in your spirit that you're
going to make it
that you're going to do it my mother she
accomplished some things against all
odds people
didn't think that she'd be able to do
that but she did it
she was determined a lot of people say
it's not over till the fat lady sings
well many people quit when she's just
clearing her throat
but my mother she was convicted
she walked by faith and not by sight my
mother
she was a no matter what person she's
still here now
she covers the ground she stands on if
you're casual about your dream
your dream will end up a casualty my
mother she
was convicted in her spirit to live a
life that
counts a a life that matters a life that
makes
impact and i think all of us are called
upon to do that and
most people died at age 25 and don't get
buried until they're 65
because they've not found something that
give their lives
meaning and purpose to make a greater
impact and here's something else not
only must you
have a life of service and belief and
inspire those around you
and caring with love and heart centered
life and
be convicted to always
looking for ways to reach higher
socrates says
a man's reaches to supersede his grasp
for water the heavens for
but the other thing is my mother had
drive
she still has it now you have to have a
drive
to get better a drive something in you
you have greatness built in you
and because of most people's lack of
drive
most people unwillingness to discover
who they are
and whose they are most people not
taking the time to work on themselves to
focus their mind to put in the
effort and to commit themselves to live
a life
that matters that stands out a life that
counts
that's that's anna marie
maria maria anna marie
oh yes my mother you can tell i'm a
mama's boy
as you look at your life here's what i
know
whatever you see yourself doing now
you're marching toward purpose
meaning and impact whatever
vision that you hold for yourself see it
accomplish
and understand this it can be done
it can be done and the glue is service
belief caring
conviction and drive
my name is evan i'm anna marie's
boy i love my mama
bye for now
there we go i love that wow man in
action is great
yeah what did you get from that
uh i love how you were able to quickly
summarize the points but also bring your
own
quotes in and all the things that that
is les brown
style you know the quotes and the
parables and the stories
um and just how you deconstructed and
made it personal that hey i'm here
telling a story
to help you get to know me a little bit
better and through
my mom as a proxy you get the message
not just me sharing
here's what you need to do but hey
here's how i learned
from my mom and you can have similar
greatness for your life too
yes now but here here where i would go
now and so ladies and gentlemen
as i look at my life now
and people might ask the question why do
you do what you do
because of things that i learned
from my mother the program that i have
showcasing
methods and techniques and inspirational
stories
and and have it be clean and family
friendly because i i know that what we
listen to we turn into i've been doing
this
for years and and at a time where
there's so many speakers out here don't
have any sense of decency
and shame about the language that we use
we
we have standards i got that from my
mother
we've been doing this for years and i
never had anything
come from my program that i would not be
proud for my mother to hear
we don't allow profanity in our
programming lest brown believe that
profanity is the strongest expression of
a weak mind
and as we look at ourselves in and out
of the pandemic
whole words have power thou shalt decree
a thing and shall be
established unto you the things that you
want to do it
can be done death and life is in the
tongue
and most of us speak death and most of
us are watching things that are killing
the positive mindset and sense of
optimism and hope and spirits
in people all around the world it's a
special time and special place
and my goal is to be david
facing these goliaths and keep in mind
goliath laws
i got five stones but i don't need but
one
and that one is service or belief
when i got some backup too
[Music]
anybody who knows you this is who you
are
you serve with your life you want to
inspire people to believe
in themselves you have a caring heart
you are convicted on the things that you
want to accomplish with your life to
live a life
that will outlive you and you have a
drive and
hunger to get better you're not
satisfied with where you are
you believe that since greatness is
possible then being excellent is not
enough
it's my honor to be in the presence of
you sir
humbled i appreciate it i i'm uh
thank you thank you for that i'm still
working on receiving you know
compliments and praise so
i i appreciate that listen
how did you come up with the concept for
the program that you have
uh which which program i'm the one where
you're showcasing speakers like myself
and you play snippets of and crystallize
and synthesize the thoughts that we
express in our speeches
so i really struggled as an entrepreneur
um when i was 19 i had my first business
and i was putting
in just tons of work and nothing was
working out
and the worst day of my life was when i
told my business partner that i quit
because i couldn't believe that i said
the words i quit on something that i
deeply cared about and the next morning
i woke up and i said i can't quit
and i had oprah's voice in my head and
she was saying you just have to find a
different way to stand
like i can't quit just find a different
way to stand
i got the idea of maybe i maybe i'm not
a dummy
maybe somebody's done this before who
else has done this
and i looked up an entrepreneur who had
built a software company before was bill
gates
and i've never met him still haven't met
him yet one day i might shake his hand
and
tell him what an impact he had in my
life and i looked at how did he start
microsoft and i took some of those
strategies and applied it to my life
and in short order had my first sale for
13 and a half thousand dollars
and at the time i was making 300 a month
so 13 and a half thousand made a just
giant world of difference and on top of
that it just showed that
finally momentum hope you know this
wasn't for nothing
um and ever since then whenever i don't
know what to do i try to model success
so whenever i don't know how to speak i
look up les brown whenever i don't know
how to
do something else i go find the person
who's done it i'm i'm not a dummy
i just need the right role models and
mentors and guides for me
and so when i figured that out i then
wanted to teach it and having my mom's
message in my ear
you have the ability so you have the
responsibility and so i just started
sharing the things that i
had learned the lessons that i loved
with other entrepreneurs out there
because i'm really just making content
for 19 year old evan who doesn't believe
in himself
who's putting in lots of work and seeing
no results and i hope that
maybe maybe it's my voice that makes an
impact or maybe the way les brown says
something
or whoever else we profile hearing it
again
from different voices in different ways
maybe it finally gives them the
breakthrough they need to believe
themselves
and realize that it's possible
come on and find a different way to
stand don't quit
on your dream find a different way to
stand because
it can be done
the goal really is just wherever you are
i want to try to create content to help
you have a little more belief in
yourself there's so much negativity
around us from the people
maybe our parents maybe our friends
maybe our classmates even
our own voice in our head is telling us
you can't do it you're not capable
you're not strong enough
and what i found is the more you can be
around the people who are doing it even
if you never get a chance to meet that
person
if you listen to if you listen to les
brown every day your life is going to
change
in a positive way he will pull you
forward and so
that's that's my goal is to uh showcase
some of the world's top talents in
different areas
and have that be your university of
excellence that you get to
listen to from your phone every single
day to pull you forward and help you
realize that that you can create amazing
things
well i tell you i'm excited this is a
time where you have to
i believe if you're serious about making
it in and out
of the pandemic that you strike
strategic partnerships and when i
stumbled across
on clubhouse when you were playing these
messages by me i said who did this
whoever did this
they spent a lot of hours putting this
together and putting my stuff together
i want to reach out and meet them and
and you were so gracious
and and opening and so i want to thank
you for that
and i'm looking forward to working with
you because i believe
it can be done and we can change the
world together
and we thank anna marie for that
[Laughter]
make sure your mother sees this and tell
me what she says
all right i will send it to her and just
as a
as a extra point of gratitude you know
when i was getting started in the
speaking business
i thought i would i would never make it
i'm introverted i'm shy my story is not
good enough nobody wants to hear from me
and when people ask me who's your who do
you think's the greatest speaker of all
time because i've seen
so many and just the nature of what i do
it's like les brown
you have to go watch les brown uh and so
you've
your videos have saved me from a lot of
dark moments have encouraged me when i
really needed the light
and it's a again tremendous honor to be
here on your show getting some live
coaching from you
and looking forward to doing more stuff
together too all right
well thank you so very much i'm going to
keep this in mind it can be
done you'll march towards finding
meaning and purpose
in life hello thank you so very much
i tell you this this is your time this
is your moment
there are millions of people that you've
touched their lives and
when they're in a dark place because of
your vision because of the stance that
you have taken with your life you've
found a different way to stand
that many people decided not to take
their lives and
and decided not to give up and throw in
the towel on themselves in their dreams
so in behalf of those thousands millions
of people around the world
i say for them thank you thank you evan
thank you you're a wonderful young man
it's an honor to meet you
bye for now if you want to see the
one-on-one i did with tony robbins check
it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there the quality of
your life has nothing to do with how
much money you have on any beautiful
children you have how many people love
you
the quality of your life is where you
live emotionally